colleen rooney and husband wayne
arriving for day two of the defamation
case that's become a public spectacle
rebecca vardy is the one suing rooney
for libel but today her own words are in
the spotlight
with rooney's lawyer alleging she turned
her connections to her husband jamie
into tabloid fodder
from rumors about riyad mahrez one of
his former teammates missing training to
an attempt to give the sun an inside
scoop on another
allegedly trying to sell a story about a
car accident involving danny drinkwater
who had moved to chelsea leading to this
text exchange between herself and her
publicist caroline watt
danny drinkwater arrested crashed his
car drunk with two girls in it both in
hospital one with broken ribs
vadi also said i want paying for this
and then later as it emerged a story had
already come out
i'm fuming i didn't give it to you
earlier
me too miss watt replied that would have
been a fortune
this image from the 2016 european
football championships was also
discussed
it was alleged vardy sat here on purpose
in one of several staged attempts to
gain publicity
this case is a celebrity circus a modern
day whodunit that has attracted the
attention of both the media and the
public but it's also taken a toll on
rebecca vardy she became emotional in
court when she spoke about the abuse
that her and her family had received
it's a case that's caused a commotion
costing hundreds of thousands of pounds
away from here though people will say
other things matter much more
but at the high court this drama goes on
vardy will continue giving evidence
tomorrow shingi marik sky news the high
court in central london